good afternoon well we start this hour
with breaking news and two men have been
arrested on suspicion of murder over the
Fatal stabbing of a footballer in
Birmingham 23 year old Cody Fisher was
stabbed on the dance floor of the crane
nightclub just before midnight on boxing
day let's go to this guy's Dan Whitehead
who joins us now from Birmingham um Dan
what does the police say
yes significant significant updates in
the investigation into the stabbing of
Cody Fisher as you say uh in the late
hours of boxing day inside the crane
Nightclub West Midlands police issuing
an update in the last couple of minutes
saying that a 22 year old has been
arrested and was held in an address in
Birmingham city center just after at
midnight last night and in addition to
that a second man aged 21 was arrested
in London they are being questioned on
suspicion of murder of Cody Fisher as
you say he was stabbed in the crane
nightclub we've had a further statement
from the lead investigator DCI Ian
Ingram from West Midlands police who has
said that we're making good progress in
our investigation and are building a
better picture of what happened we've
been really pleased with the response
from the public and have already had a
number of witness accounts and images
sent through which will help our
investigation it goes on to say that it
is it is vital that we hear from
everybody
who saw any part of what happened that
night no matter how insignificant they
think it might be Cody's family and
friends are devastated by what happened
and will continue to bring them uh
answers so a significant update nearly
two days on from uh this attack which
happened uh inside a very busy nightclub
in Birmingham hundreds of people willing
were inside at the crane nightclub on
boxing day uh night and we understand
one of those Cody was dancing with
friends in as part of a group who had
gone out that night to celebrate uh
Christmas and that is when he was
fatally stabbed and died on that dance
floor we're outside Stratford Town
Football Club which was the football
club uh some 40 minutes south of that
nightclub where Cody played and we heard
yesterday from the chairman of the club
um this is a group of young men who have
been absolutely devastated by at this
news we understand that a number of them
were with Cody in the Nightclub at the
time and tributes paid from this club
and other non-league clubs including
bromsgrove which uh Cody played for last
season there's been messages as well on
social media of course
um one from A lady called Jess Chatwin
we don't know the exact relation to uh
Cody but she has gone on Instagram and
Twitter putting up pictures of them
together as a couple saying you didn't
deserve any of this I'm so sorry this
happened to you my baby please come home
I love you forever Cody Fisher that's
the message from her and tributes as
well from schools because Cody not only
played for Stratford town but he was a
football coach at primary schools in the
area providing inspiration to young
people in the Birmingham area at one of
those schools Woodrow first school now
I've spoken to the Head teachers today
they are devastated as well by the loss
of someone he clearly was very
inspirational to those in the classroom
there at Woodrow everyone at the school
is devastated to hear of the tragic and
needless death of this bright friendly
and talented uh young man this of course
is a fast-paced investigation that there
is a significant police
a presence still at crane nightclub and
although the police say they are making
Headway and of course they have now made
two arrests they are still Keen to hear
from people who are inside that club it
was incredibly busy it is a large club
and we understand hundreds of people
were in there to enjoy the DJs that were
performing on that night and they're
especially asking for people who have
photos or possibly videos of their night
to send them through so that the
detectives in charge can make an
assessment as to whether or not it is
relevant but the main updates that we
have this afternoon is the first arrests
on suspicion of murder
of Cody Fisher that 22 year old held in
Birmingham last night just after
midnight and a 21 year old also arrested
in London